so my name is Thomas Jabin I work for a
come
Absalom I'm a project leader in software
engineer but in this presentation I'll
be talking about my personal interest
which is a natural language processing
and specifically generative text
modeling and this presentation I hope to
give you an overview of the recent
advancements of the ways in which we can
generate text so to begin with
generative text modeling language models
ubiquitous but sometimes we're just not
aware of them so just to give you a
first hint like one of the very simple
language models that we have already
smartphones is the one that predicts the
next word as we typing the other ones
has such things last spell checkers or
our Corrections sure yeah
tory's yeah the next topic I just wanted
to briefly hint at the at the very
beginning is one two one two okay the
next topic I wanted to briefly hint is
from the headlines that you might have
seen they look a little bit scary but
actually they're coming from and
trustful sources like Guardian or BBC or
Wall Street Journal is they are going to
eat us with fake news generated entirely
on their own
I hope and later part in the
presentation to give you my view on on
this point I don't think the word is
that scary and finally you might have
been playing with the websites like rock
tune transformer or right wave
transformer where you just input some
prefix and later the website actually
the model on the line on the website
generates text so actually on the right
hand side you see sample like just copy
paste it from the PI data website and if
you look at the bold text it's actually
the one that's generated by the GPT to
model it looks well in my opinion there
are some repetitions but well you could
believe that this was
actually by human okay
I mentioned word quality so how can we
measure quality one idea is to just to
compare loss function of the model and
to verify that one model is better than
the other but since we're telling us
about the absolute quality of the model
the common way to compare the models is
to measure perplexity so if you don't
know the perplexity is a very fancy word
for confusion so we want to basically
verify how confused our model is once we
provide it with sample text and verify
how probable it would be for the model
to generate it and usually we calculate
it as a to ^ cross and throw pillows and
the final very common method of actually
verifying the output of the model is a
qualitative judgment it's basically a
human reading a text and saying yes it's
a good quality yeah but there are also
other ways to determine the quality of
the language model as
the models have became more and more
sophisticated they're able to perform
more and more sophisticated tasks so for
example one of the tasks is to be into
being able to answer a question like in
the test called I think it's spelt wine
a broad schema challenge so it's
basically we provide a model some sample
text and we ask a simple question what
is too big this is a an example of a
task that you might find it's very easy
right we obviously know that too big is
the trophy but for the model is not that
easy to data like that that too big
close actually relates to the trophy the
other case is the Lambada it's also
similar ideas so we basically provide a
longer passage and we verify like which
word has the largest probability of
being outputted for us it's also quite
easy to interfere from the previous
passage which word is the most likely
but for the model it's not that easy
and basically state-of-the-art models
are being verified by the benchmarks
like superglue you could have heard some
time ago that language models became
better than humans in understanding or
generating text this was thinking with
the previous benchmark called glue which
was a little bit easier and the new
version of the of the benchmark called
superglue contains tasks that are just
more sophisticated and more difficult
for the for the models and so far the
human baseline is not yet beaten but as
you see the average score of the human
baselines is right now very close to the
best model from Google okay so
generative text modeling so let's first
of all think if we were to quickly like
hack some some modeling of the text on
some particular topic how could we
approach it so the first example is
coming from website that you might know
it's actually a quite famous website
used for bikini hotels and if you have
been searching for your accommodation
for the conference for long enough then
you could have spotted that some offers
have very repetitive passages that they
look a little bit artificial and
obviously if we take a closer look there
are some passages from other offers that
would look very similar so this looks
like a template based way of generating
text so it looks like this but the
problem of this approach is that it's
static and repetitive so the text looks
a little bit artificial and it has quite
limited use cases the ones that should
craft the templates for and also is very
difficult to create the templates that
will be grasping the concepts like
morphology or punctuation agreement and
paragraphs especially it becomes very
difficult in Polish as we have so many
different cases and corner cases
there was this kind of a drawback so if
you want to have full control of what
the output is of the watts model is
outputting then you'd probably create
something like a template-based model
but if you want to allow some kind of
flexibility then you probably go for the
neural or end-to-end approaches if you
want something in between there are
approaches that are called hybrid but I
won't be covering them in this
presentation so onwards to the very
first model that you could have learnt
during your classes some kind of natural
language processing is the Markov model
being fed with the engrams so the
general idea is super simple you
basically feed in the data you calculate
the engrams and their kinds of
occurrences later at the generation step
you once you want to generate actually I
can use the example that I have just
crafted so we have an example Uncle Bob
attended there we have a sliding window
the sliding window moves and we want to
generate the next word so we basically
look at the engrams and minus one rooms
with the prefix attended and we look at
the kinds of occurrences there is a
distribution and we sample from it and
we have a next word but there is a
problem this doesn't really contain any
meaning there is if you make the end too
small you're not fully treating
sentences on particular topic you're
just like wandering randomly around your
corpus if you pick n that's too big you
are basically repeating the sentences
from your corpus which is also bad so a
quick jump to more recent advancements
which are called Ireland's recurrent
neural networks so in this idea we're
using recurrent link that allows us to
transfer the knowledge between the
multiple time steps so in the basic
formulation of it because of the
problems like vanishing gradient or
exploding gradient it became really
tricky to pass the knowledge from one
time step to another time step
I'm also saying timestep because like we
kinda we're not who are perfectly fit
for sequential kind of data so as an
extension architectures like Alice T
Ames so long short-term memories or
grated weekend units have been invented
and they allow to pass the information
much more effectively so I know if you
remember about something around four
years ago they used to be a paper by
Andrew karpati actually the blog post by
Andrew karpati that created set of
experiments using a very simple regard
or network that was based on the
character level and he was just feeding
various types of data and he was
receiving a very convincing results so
for example one kind of result this is
basically an output of a model that was
failing with later data this looks like
a passage from your math textbook but it
doesn't really have any sense actually
in some cases I think no it's not this
not this example buttons some other
examples the model also like to omit the
proofs quite convincing right the other
super interesting experiment was to feed
in the Linux kernel code into the
recurrent neural network and once again
we're talking about the network that's
just using character level level of
abstraction so once again the network
learn to produce code that looks very
convincing although it doesn't compile
on this life there is a visualization of
certain firings of the neurons so there
are neurons that for example learned
what is a comment and they learned to
turn on whenever the network was
actually in the comment the network also
learned the concept of the level of
indentation so that's all very promising
but once take a like closer look it
doesn't have any sense so the language
like the language model didn't really
process any knowledge it's just
basically how the characters fit in
to each other
so that approach is using the generative
adversarial networks so you probably
know what the generative adversarial
network is it's basically a set of two
neural networks that compete with each
other so the generator tries to fold the
discriminator by producing more and more
convincing results by transforming the
random uniform distribution into
distribution that it's kind of desired
like for example the celebrity faces and
then the discriminator learns how to
distinguish those celebrity faces that
are real and fake so the overall
discriminator tries to learn how to be
best at this at this kind of distinction
and the generator tries to become best
at fooling the discriminator but there
is a problem so it works really well
with continuous data like for example
images celebrity faces images are just
pixels like we can easily alter the
pixel value because it's just a number
and then we can back propagate it so how
do you work with discrete like for
example sequence of characters or tokens
so basically two approaches that I just
wanted to mention the first one is
called gamble softmax trick that at the
output of the generator if you imagine
that the generator output is a vector
sized as the size of vocabulary and it
outputs the probability of the next word
if you want to back propagate through it
we can't really say we just like pick
the max probability and we take it out
to the discriminator face we need to
sample somehow from it so here comes the
Gumbel distribution so we basically add
the value from the Gumbel distribution
but again we can't really take the arc
max because our max is not
differentiable so in order to provide
differentiability we use soft Max and
additionally we can also use parameter
called temperature so by uttering the
temperature we are altering how much the
temperature the the overall function
looks like an arc Max and the second
approach utilizes reinforcement Lane
learning so in this case this is
actually diagram from paper describing
second the approaches so that the
generator is a reinforcement learning
agent and it generates next tokens as we
go and the discriminative feeds in value
from the environment as a reward whoever
the next generated token was good or bad
and this way the generator can alter its
policy to output more and more
convincing words yeah but lately all the
hype was about the transformers and the
potential mechanism so this is a very
fashion that advancement coming from I
think two years ago from a paper called
attentional need and this diagram shows
the basic idea from it I will be going
in in too much detail about like meaning
of each exact box but I just wanted to
[Music]
yeah it works so basically the left-hand
side is called the encoder and the
encoder learns the key value pairs
allows to extract the key value pairs
from the text we'd call it like it lands
how to so in the recurrent neural
network we were hoping so that the
knowledge will somehow propagate over
the recurrent or link and transformer
architecture it learns the key value
pairs that not some kind of knowledge we
don't know like what exactly will be
will end up there but the network will
figure it out itself on the right hand
side is the part that's usually called
decoder and learns the queries and later
in this module
multi-head attention
these things are joined and for the
queries we are picking the value that
key is the closest in some space to the
key
and the overall idea is that when we
read a text it's not actually reading we
not actually reading talking by talking
it's not saying that the word there is
of the same importance as any other word
so we paying different attention to
different parts of the text and the
model tries to learn these associations
between the query and target values and
actually most of the recent models that
have been at the top I think probably
all of them of the super-boob benchmark
I showed couple slides earlier are using
some variation on transformers
so what's kind of puzzling about this
it's that transformers really learn how
to a model a long time dependency really
well so if you play with the demo on the
writing with transformer or like talk to
transform a website you see that the
quality is superb but also the models as
outlined by the GPT
- paper the models are learning
surprising amount of the domain
knowledge like for example who's the
President of the United States like
suddenly the knowledge that's somehow
baked into the training data is being
persisted into the model and the model
is able to answer this kind of questions
were surprisingly good accuracy so the
the fake news part it's been promised
somehow in the the abstract so we've
been flooded with these headlines that
are scaring us that suddenly the GPT 2
will start outputting very convincing
text but if you look at this text it
does not convincing right like there is
a man and she boasts to do business with
you and it's like serious money so so
actually how does it work so that for
some people that write some random
things we say no no no no but for others
we say yeah it's totally this
in my opinion it's actually we build
credibility by some kind of authority so
once we see that someone has particular
number of likes or particular number of
comments then this person suddenly
becomes a credible person and probably
has some kind of a knowledge and this
may be making us like convinced so that
the earth is not really that round or
and what makes me actually skirt is that
the latest advancements in the models
are becoming really impressive so
actually I think last week
uber has released new model that's
called plug-and-play language model so
in this approach they they have
presented it allows you to train a very
small model that allows you to for
example distinguish what's toxic speech
and what's not toxic not non toxic
speech and later you can reuse that
model to drive somehow the generation of
the gbt to output so in a way you can
say okay now I want to actually write
toxic speech and the GPT to will be
doing exactly that
so you're getting much more control over
what you're actually generating and if
you are able to generate not only
conditioned on the topic but also on the
style or some other various features
then it becomes heavily convincing let's
try something hands-on well it's not
actually that hands-on I have basically
before the presentation
I have prepared a very simple language
model just to kind of ease the tension
it's a recurrent neural network it's
three layers of LS TM there's a drop out
it's a network that we'll be feeding in
characters and we'll be trying to
predict the next characters based on
that so sounds like super simple like
for based on the the output of the last
layer I think the size was two and a
half million neurons so that's not that
much
I have trained it on Google co-op just
because I'm on a tight budget so I took
corpus out of Wikipedia I think it was
16 megabytes large and I put it into
this network and this is what happened I
didn't want to present you like any
sophisticated graphs of loss functions
because it doesn't really like put us
anywhere also the model ring didn't
really like achieve that much accuracy
anyway but if you take a look like over
the iterations in the table you start to
see that some kind of patterns appear
like this is basically a sample
conditioned on the prefix it's Vic where
or incredible so suddenly these words
try to look convincing at least like
polish like at the iteration 45 you
suddenly see that there are more and
more words that look like from Polish
language okay
also try something more fun so I fed in
punted out like all of it no
pre-processing let's just see what
happens and condition it on prefix 10
good verses since good verse is one of
the main characters somehow appearing
throughout the pages so many times so
actually if you take a look at iteration
like 400 600 suddenly we see other
character names so the network actually
learns surprising things out of it I'm
not saying like we would use it in some
kind of production environment but just
a fun experiment to show you that well
you don't bring any sophisticated
transformer to achieve surprising
results okay practical use cases how can
I actually use language models for my
own users on my own usage there is a
wonderful library called hugging phase
transformers hugging phases the company
transformers is the name of the library
and it contains language models from the
past couple of years with between
weights which you can very easily
interface with you can just basically
with four lines of code you can have
your own GPT to running on your own
machine generating
and conditioned samples it also has
really nice capabilities to do some kind
of fine-tuning or transfer learning for
some more specific tasks so for example
if you'd like to do some kind of more
sophisticated sentiment analysis this
might be a really nice thing to take a
look at suddenly it's mostly English the
models are mostly in English there are
some models in French German I think I
saw something also in Romanian models
that are multilingual not really fit for
generating the language they also have
issues with understanding like what kind
of language you really wants to see at a
really interesting thing that's in this
library is are the Distilled models so
distillation is a technique that allowed
creation of the models that are orders
of magnitude smaller but also have very
similar accuracy or perceived quality of
the output text so it's really cool
because you can have your language model
of the quality of I think Bert running
in on your iPhone 7 so that's that's
actually really cool sadly if you want
to train your proper language model from
scratch using these kind of
architectures it is very costly because
we're talking about the models that have
hundreds of millions up to like 1.2
billion the largest one parameters in
order to train them you need to spend at
least $10,000 and that's basically
without any kind of high performance
tuning so probably can multiply that by
some reasonable number so what are the
takeaways I would like you to take away
from this talk is that language models
are reaching a point so that the output
of them is convincing also I just
mentioned it language models that allow
you to control various features actually
you can if you go to the hugging face
that call transformers or something like
this you can see how many different
parameters you can alter when you
play with the uber model ppl em in short
the models like GPT to our learning
surprising amount of trivia knowledge
and if you want to do some kind of
transfer learning that's probably a good
thing to do and yeah looking at those
models that I have just showed like from
the slide from Aaron ends up to now
we're talking about span of four years
so I just wanted to leave you with this
thought like who knows how this
presentation would look like next year
thanks
[Applause]